entonces tenemos aquí una fuente que
está emitiendo una onda y además esta
fuente se está moviendo hacia la derecha
ok entonces vamos a ponerle aquí a qué
velocidad se está moviendo
entonces la velocidad de la fuente es
igual a una cantidad de s hacia la
derecha lo que vamos a hacer en este
vídeo es básicamente lo que hicimos en
el vídeo pasado pero de una forma más
abstracta para poder obtener la fórmula
general para la frecuencia observada
entonces de ese es qué tan rápido se
está moviendo este puntito hacia la
derecha la fuente de la onda y también
sería muy bueno saber qué tan rápido se
propaga la onda que está emitiendo este
puntito entonces vamos a decir que la
velocidad de la onda es igual a una
cantidad a la que vamos a llamarle wv y
la onda se desplaza radialmente hacia
afuera ok
siempre que vemos una velocidad tenemos
que dar una magnitud y una dirección y
esta onda va a tener una frecuencia y un
periodo pero esa frecuencia y ese
periodo va a estar asociado a el punto
donde se emitió la onda y la fuente de
emisión o sea este puntito
y esto es mecánica clásica no nos vamos
a meter con velocidades relativas ni con
velocidades cercanas a la velocidad de
la luz para no tener que preocuparnos
por todas esas cosas raras que pasan
cuando la velocidad se acerca a la
velocidad de la luz y todo el asunto de
la física relativista más adelante
podrán meterse a cosas de relatividad
pero por el momento vamos a quedarnos
con la física clásica muy bien pero este
puntito emite la onda y él lo que
observa es que está emitiendo con cierto
periodo y a éste a ese periodo que
observa este esta fuente de la onda que
le está emitiendo le vamos a llamar
periodo de la fuente periodo de la
fuente
lo vamos a denotar por de sub s y bueno
también observando desde la fuente
observando desde este puntito la onda
que está emitiendo este punto tiene
también una frecuencia y a esa
frecuencia observado desde este punto le
vamos a llamar la frecuencia desde la
fuente
frecuencia desde la fuente
y la vamos a denotar por efe su veces
bueno aquí periodo de la fuente
realmente le debimos haber puesto
periodo desde la fuente
y como seguro recuerdan del vídeo pasado
estas dos cantidades son inversas la una
de la otra o sea te s es igual a 1 / efe
s y lo mismo f es igual a 1 entre t s ok
esta mide cuánto tiempo se tarda la onda
en completar un ciclo y esta mide
cuántos ciclos caben o qué fracción del
ciclo cabe en un segundo entonces
terminan siendo inversos el uno del otro
bueno y ahora ya que tenemos toda la
anotación veamos qué es lo que pasa o
sea digamos en el tiempo igual a cero o
sea justo en este segundo este puntito
emite una cresta emite un pulso ok
ahorita ni siquiera lo puedes ver porque
como justo lo está emitiendo ahorita no
se ha desplazado ni un solo centímetro
ni milímetro de donde está haciendo
emitido
por qué
pero ahora vayámonos hacia el futuro
veamos cómo se ve esta cresta dentro de
estos segundos y por qué dentro de estos
segundos pues porque dentro de ts
segundos nuestro puntito va a emitir la
siguiente cresta entonces donde
dibujamos la primera cresta que emitió
este puntito pues tenemos que averiguar
qué distancia recorrió la onda en esa
cantidad de tiempo no y como averiguamos
eso pues simplemente multiplicamos la
velocidad con la que se traslada a la
onda sea la velocidad de la onda por la
cantidad del tiempo que dejamos que se
traslade y eso nos va a dar la distancia
que recorrió que que no crees que eso me
va a dar una distancia a ver dejamos un
ejemplo o sea pongamos una velocidad aht
y arbitraria por ejemplo 5 metros sobre
segundo eso sí es una velocidad no o sea
una unidad de velocidad si son metros
sobre segundo no y multipliquemos la por
cierta cantidad de tiempo por ejemplo
segundos y qué es lo que nos queda 5 por
2 nos queda 10 y los segundos se
cancelan con segundos y nos queda nada
más metros ok ahora sí ya tiene más
sentido que velocidad por tiempo me dé
una distancia porque los metros indican
distancia y bueno pasa exactamente lo
mismo cuando multiplicamos la velocidad
de la onda por un tiempo o sea nos
tienen que dar una distancia y en este
caso pues tiene que ser la distancia que
ha recorrido el primer pulso de la onda
en un tiempo ts ok vamos a empezar por
dibujar más o menos donde creemos que
está la cresta por aquí está la primera
cresta
esta distancia
o sea el radio de esta circunferencia
porque recuerden que la onda se está
transmitiendo radialmente hacia afuera o
sea o sea se está moviendo en todas
direcciones
ok justo aquí se está emitiendo el
siguiente pulso y el tiempo que pasa
entre que se emitió el primer impulso y
el segundo es justo ts y la onda se
mueve hacia afuera a una velocidad b&w
entonces digamos que empezó aquí y
empezó con una velocidad b&w y después
esperamos ts segundos y queremos saber
qué distancia se trasladó entonces lo
que tenemos que hacer es multiplicar wv
por t s y eso es exactamente
esta distancia
ahora este puntito que es la fuente que
está emitiendo la onda se está moviendo
hacia la derecha con una velocidad bs
entonces en realidad pues en este
momento osea ts segundos después de que
emitió la primera cresta se encuentra
como dibujemos lo por acá ok esto lo que
significa osa dibujarlo adentro del
círculo adentro del primer pulso que
emitió esto lo que significa es que la
velocidad con la que se mueve el objeto
es estrictamente menor que la velocidad
con la que se traslada la onda y en este
vídeo vamos a trabajar con esta
hipótesis cosas muy interesantes pasan
cuando no se preserva esta desigualdad o
sea cuando la velocidad con la que se
mueve el objeto es igual a la velocidad
con la que se mueve la onda o incluso
puede ser mayor
y esas cosas pues las vamos a ver en los
próximos vídeos pero por el momento nos
vamos a quedar con esto entonces si
podemos pintar a nuestro puntito a
nuestro objeto que está emitiendo la
onda adentro del círculo que representa
el primer pulso que emitió
ok pero obviamente también vamos a
querer calcular cuál es esta distancia y
para hacerlo vamos a hacer exactamente
lo mismo que para hacer esto ok
estamos justo en ese momento donde este
objeto está emitiendo la siguiente onda
pero todavía no la emite ok y entonces
como estamos justo en ese momento han
transcurrido ts segundos desde que
emitió la otra onda
ok cuando emitió la otra onda estaba en
este punto por lo cual esta distancia la
podemos calcular como pues multiplicando
la velocidad con la que se traslada el
objeto o sea de ese por el tiempo que ha
transcurrido o sea de s
y cómo vamos a poner a un observador por
acá
pues estaría muy bien calcular cuál es
la distancia entre la primera cresta y
la segunda cresta que justo en este
momento es la distancia entre la primera
cresta y el punto que está emitiendo la
onda okay cuál es esa distancia pues
esta distancia es tal cual esta
distancia
- esta distancia ok y esta distancia es
exactamente igual a esta distancia es
tal cual cuanto se ha trasladado la
primera cresta desde el punto original o
sea es v w x t s
menos la distancia que se ha trasladado
el puntito que es de ese porte s
y de paso vamos a borrar esto para que
no nos estorbe solo recuerden lo muy
bien y ahora si tú eres el observador tú
estás sentado aquí y estás justo
escuchando la primera cresta que emitió
este puntito cuánto tiempo vas a tener
que esperar para escuchar la segunda
cresta que imita el puntito aunque ya
tenemos aquí la distancia y lo que te
estoy preguntando es cuánto tiempo
pasará entre que escuches la primera
cresta y la segunda cresta
indirectamente lo que te estoy
preguntando es tú qué periodo vas a
observar
ok porque como vimos en el vídeo pasado
no va a ser el mismo periodo que observa
la fuente que observa el puntito ok
entonces pues vamos a escribirlo por acá
o el periodo desde el punto de vista del
observador
y para calcularlo pues aquí ya tenemos
la distancia que tienen que recorrer la
onda y ya sabemos cuál es la velocidad
con la cual la onda se transmite
entonces ya tenemos todo lo que
necesitamos aquí tal vez te acuerdes de
la fórmula de que la velocidad es igual
a la distancia sobre tiempo en el
ejemplo que acabo de borrar de la
velocidad de 5 metros sobre segundos y
los 2 segundos pues realmente lo que
teníamos era una forma despejada de esta
fórmula o sea tenemos por aquí el tiempo
y aquí tenemos la distancia y ahora lo
que queremos es despejar el tiempo
entonces vamos a pasar la velocidad de
hacia abajo esta la vamos a pasar para
acá y lo que nos queda es que el tiempo
es igual a la distancia entre la
velocidad
recuerda lo muy bien porque es muy útil
y lo voy a borrarse ok aquí tenemos 30
que es el tiempo que estamos buscando
entonces vamos a buscar la distancia que
es esta y la vamos a dividir entre la
velocidad y eso nos va a dar el tiempo
entonces déjame copio esto lo muevo para
acá entonces tiempo es igual la
distancia entre velocidad porque la
distancia que tienen que recorrer la
nueva cresta que es justo está entre la
velocidad con la cual se propaga la onda
que es de doble uve y enlistó obtenemos
el tiempo que te vas a tardar tu sentado
en este punto en escuchar la siguiente
cresta ok entonces este
es el periodo que observa cualquier
persona que se coloque en este lugar en
medio de la trayectoria de este objeto
que el periodo desde este punto de vista
y ya que tenemos el periodo obviamente
podemos calcular nada más poniendo uno
entre la frecuencia que observa esta
persona ahora podemos manipular esta
expresión un poquito más
y aquí esto lo podemos factorizar como
ts que está multiplicando a los dos
humanos del numerador osea ts x
de w - de s / v w ok y tal cual ahorita
ya acá vamos a hacer una fórmula general
que te da que periodo observa este
observador que está justo en el camino
de este puntito en términos que utilizan
únicamente el periodo desde la fuente o
sea desde el puntito la velocidad con la
que se propaga la onda y la velocidad
con la que el puntito se mueve o sea con
esta fórmula que sacamos lo único que
necesitas es que te den el periodo de la
onda la velocidad de la onda y la
velocidad con la que el punto se mueve a
la derecha para saber perfectamente qué
periodo va a observar esta persona
parada aquí en este puntito ya nada más
tienes que sustituir los valores y listo
y bueno si queremos la frecuencia
observada desde este punto pues nada más
tenemos que tomar el inverso o sea 1
entre esto así es que la frecuencia
observada desde este
observador
1 / esta cosa lo cual termina siendo wv
/
por wwf s por toda esta onda esto es
justo la frecuencia desde la fuente
porque entonces esto se vuelve igual a
frecuencia de la fuente o sea la
frecuencia observada desde el puntito
por wv /
w s ok esta es tal cual la frecuencia
observada desde el punto de vista del
observador
ok esta es la frecuencia observada desde
el punto de vista del observador o sea
desde aquí
y esto de aquí es justo en la fórmula
general para obtener el periodo desde el
punto de vista del observador en el
próximo vídeo vamos a hacer exactamente
lo mismo vamos a calcular estas dos
fórmulas de cómo obtener el periodo
desde el punto de vista del observador y
la frecuencia desde el punto de vista
del observador pero para un observador
que se encuentre más bien en este punto